Ninh explains the rules of kabaddi.
Kabaddi is an Indian sport played with two teams of 12 players,...
...with seven players taking to the court at any one time.
The game is played on a rectangular court...
...that's generally a maximum of 30 meters by 10 meters.
This is a midline that divides the court into two,...
...and these are the baulk lines, the end lines, the bonus lines...
...and this is the lobby area.
I'll explain what these are shortly.
The object of the game is for your team to score more points than the opposing team.
To score, a team must send a player, known as a raider,...
...into the opposing half of the court...
...whilst chanting the word "kabaddi" repeatedly.
A raider must only use one breath and chant the word "kabaddi" repeatedly...
...to show the referee that he is exhaling and not holding his breath.
The first goal of the raider is to reach the baulk line.
Failure to do this results in the raider being out,...
...and cannot participate in the next part of the game.
The second goal of the raider is to touch as many players as he can...
...and make it back to the midline before he is caught and tackled by the defenders.
He can do this in several ways.
With a hand touch, a toe touch, a kick...
...or by trying to escape a tackle and reaching for the midline.
He gets one point for every opposing defender that he touches...
...so long as he makes it back to the midline,...
...all whilst repeatedly chanting the word "kabaddi."
And any touched defenders are out and cannot participate in the next round of play.